the needy person is a stock figure of
caricature they call too much they cry
when you leave to get a glass of water
they feel put out when you check your
phone they were upset when you watched a
film without them we hate needy people a
lot but let's look at this another way
there are of course a few pathologically
dependent people at large but a lot of
the time far more than is generally
accepted the person who has the problem
isn't the needy person at all it's us
the ones who are doing the accusing we
will feel that someone is sickeningly
needy when we don't see ourselves as
appropriate targets of someone else's
need somewhere inside we don't trust
that we are reliable strong dependable
admirable or decent we aren't quite
grown-up and those who need something
from us therefore come across as
deranged and fitting targets for mockery
at the first sign that someone is
becoming reliant on us we flinch
we suspect that someone who needs us
enough to depend on us for a pleasant
weekend or an evening must be diseased
at the root of our hatred of so-called
needy people is self-hatred ostensibly
we all want love but when love actually
starts to be reciprocated it may prove
intensely alarming if we're not
convinced of our own love ability we can
start to think very badly of the person
we liked only a little time before we
feel they're naive in finding us
wonderful a great deal more wonderful
than we feel we are we think them
gullible and too easily taken in by a
character we ourselves don't believe in
the solution isn't necessarily to try to
change a lover by telling them to stop
asking so much they most probably aren't
asking too much at all they just aren't
afflicted with a sense that it's
peculiar to be loved or to love put
another way they're just strong enough
to reveal that they aren't invulnerable
and judicious enough to like the look of
us they rightly presume that showing
need is a precondition of strength
rather than weakness the solution is to
revise our view of ourselves
to see ourselves as more or less
plausible people for someone else to
stand in need of the fear of needy
people is only a species of self-hatred
rippling outwards to tar our lover a
reduction of self-hatred doesn't depend
on self boosterism
telling ourselves how great we are we
should learn to tolerate ourselves not
by believing that we are wonderful but
via a secure realization that everyone
is both okay and sometimes a bit awful
that is enough to deserve life we can be
cured of our uncommon ly vicious self
suspicion by a more accurate vision of
what constitutes normality of course
we're a bit weak a bit sly and a bit
foolish to put it gently but so is
everyone we're no more idiotic or
wayward than the next person we can
embrace a person's hopes for a close and
deep relationship with us simply on the
basis that we are in fact all a bit odd
and broken but the need that the lover
has of us isn't delusional it's an
accurate request that any flawed human
might make of another comparably damaged
example we'll start to find other people
a lot less needy that is a lot less
alarming when they need us when we can
accept with a good grace that there is
nothing unusually strange or abhorrent
about someone deciding they like us
[Music]
you